d-back starter today the left-hander
madison bumgarner
hopeful to finish up with his first win
as a diamondback don't throw him another
strike you're heading the count oh and
two right now then bounce a couple throw
one up over his head see if you can get
him to chase a bad pitch like that there
it is
good start for mad balm one away amazing
bat to ball skills this year since he
cut down on his swing
but he refuses to walk so don't throw
him another strike
arson kelly back there with madison
bumgarner
fastball at 90 is there for strikeout
number two
just missed away with a cutter to the
back door and then comes right back
inside with that four-seam fastball
popped them up
gotta get somebody over there matt bum's
gonna do it all by himself for one two
three first diamondbacks coming up
against kyle freeland
kyle freeland 369 earned run average he
shaved three runs off his era from a
year ago
nicole leads all the diamondbacks with
the 15 home run
but his own for six in the series le
castro at third
getall at second and walker at first
base hit for calhoun le castro's home
they will stop cattell at third and it's
one nothing diamondbacks
well if you hit it hard enough you can
bang it right through an exaggerated
pull shift and that's what cole calhoun
does here on this slider right in the
middle of the plate
i'm at a 262 and five homers
on the ground to third mcmahon gets one
and
they can't turn two as cattell scores
from third
to make it two nothing safe is the call
at first by john lipka
cole calhoun's been a really good fit
hadn't he yeah he's a stud
calhoun swings it's a fly ball to pretty
deep center field
here here goes back looks up and this
one is gone
two run over for cole calhoun and it's
four nothing diamondbacks
fourth call number 16. he's driven in
three today and he gets to 40 on the
season
there's your mvp he crushed that ball
right into the overhang just didn't
just a little bit right at center field
nicole calhoun
he's one guy that's really sad to see 20
20 come to an end he's finishing really
strong
four nothing d backs and a big day going
on for calhoun
three rbis he's in scoring positions
still with only one man out in the
batter it's nick ahmed
and a fly ball center field hillyard
going back
going back looking up this balls off the
wall escobar will come in to score
and nick will stop at second with an rbi
double i don't know what hilliard was
doing on that
he knew that ball i guess was going to
hit on the wall and
he just turned his back to the home
plate and waited for a ricochet
that ball was hit so hard off the bat
that i think he knew right away
there's no way he was catching up with
that and again nick ahmed just
continues his dominance over kyle
freeland marshall is knocked in eight
strikeout looking out to be thrown out
to on the first stunning first pitch to
it
second pitch make that ground ball to
second the throw the plane is bad on the
run scores
terrible throw from hampson and ahmed
scored
with a slide boulders had to go up the
first base line to get the ball and it
was bounced to it
i mean hampton sometimes plays center
field and it looked like he was
a dh trying to throw that ball i mean
just a lousy throw
a one-hopper perfect to him
matheson knocks that down deflected to
ahmed off the bat of hampstead who runs
well and somehow
they got the speedy second baseman at
first base
five six three on your score card right
there really scoop down that line wyatt
matheson played
shallow with a diving attempt just
deflected it over to his shortstop nick
ahmed who makes a
great running throw on the move just in
time to get hampson at first base
what a play midfield creeping in for
colorado
artes sends one out to left poppy is
there
here comes carson
was deflected by mcmahon make it seven
nothing
and an rbi for cattell
[Music]
in this series this is the 18th
plate appearance for the diamondbacks
with the bases loaded
on it at third varsa at second
matheson's at first here it is
carson takes a rip down the line
no it lands in there it's fair
ahmed will jog home here comes varshall
matheson is gonna stop at third it's a
two-run double
for carson kelly are you not entertained
[Music]
tapia looked for sure like he was going
to get to the spot
but somehow he didn't quite catch it and
stayed fair
[Applause]
del marty has doubled walked scored
twice and knocked in a room
and look what he's done with his
opportunity martay drops it into right
center this will get two more runs in
and it's 11 to nothing face it into
right center field drives home two more
giving him three on the day
i think that'll probably end it for to
[Applause]
[Applause]
you better put two guys over there when
he comes up and then it's
bobbled out there by le castro and
tony's gonna come around and score
there's a chance for riley smith the 3-2
struck him on and riley smith strikes
out the side
to close out the 2020 season with an
11-3
diamondbacks win